UP BLAMING THE VOTERS ONCE AGAI
AGAIN.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS ROBERT RALPH,
SENIOR FELLOW IN CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA WERE
SURE JUST LIKE IN ALL OF THESE
OTHER PREDICTIONS THAT WERE
FLOPS, THEY WERE SURE
YESTERDAY'S RULING WOULD COMPEL
JOHN BOLTON TO TESTIFY AND THEN
HIS LAWYER SAYS DEMOCRATS AGAIN
ARE HAVING TO CHASE THE
ROADRUNNER.
THEY ARE GOING TO END UP WITH
THE TNT BLOWING UP IN THEIR
FACES.
>> THE JUDGE MADE VERY CLEAR
ALTHOUGH THE TOP WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS DON'T HAVE ABSOLUTE
IMMUNITY FROM SHOWING UP TO
TESTIFY THAT THEY CAN CLAIM
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND RESPONSE
TO SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ANYTIME A
QUESTION ARISES AND EVEN HAVE
THE WHITE HOUSE CURRENT COUNCIL
THERE TO ADVISE THEM WHEN TO
EXERT EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
IT MAY HAVE SOUNDED LIKE A WIN
BUT THEY OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T GET
PAST PAGE TWO OR THREE.
>> Laura: I'M TALKING ABOUT A
BOLTON, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
TAKES THAT ANALYSIS TO THE NEXT
STEP.
THEY THOUGHT JOHN BOLTON WAS
GOING TO BE AGAIN THE NIRVANA IN
THIS WHOLE IMPEACHMENT QUEST
THAT THEY HAVE.
BUT BOLTON'S LAWYERS, THEY DON'T
SEEM LIKE THEY ARE ANY RUSH TO
GET UP THERE AND TESTIFY EITHER.
THEY ARE EITHER REALLY BAD AT
MAKING PREDICTIONS OR THEY DON'T
KNOW THE LAW OR THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO READ AN OPINION OR THAT
THE OPINION IS LIMITED TO A
CERTAIN SET OF SPECIAL FACTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS BUT IT'S
GETTING EMBARRASSING NOW HOW
REPEATEDLY WRONG THE DEMOCRATS
ARE ON A MYRIAD OF ISSUES.
>> IT'S ALSO ONLY ONE JUDGE
WHICH MEANS IT IS NOT ON BOLTON.
LET'S JUST START WITH THE VERY
BASICS RIGHT THERE.
SECOND THING IS THE DECISION
ALREADY HAS BEEN APPEALED, A
NOTICE OF APPEAL WAS FILED TODAY
WITH A REQUEST FOR A STAY.
I IMAGINE WE WILL SEE THAT
POSSIBLY AS EARLY AS TOMORROW
EITHER BY THE DISTRICT JUDGE OR
IF THE DISTRICT JUDGE DOESN'T DO
IT, THE D.C. CIRCUIT IS LIKELY
TO DO IT FOR HER.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS ON THIS
TIMETABLE THERE'S NO WAY YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A DECISION FROM
THE D.C. CIRCUIT THAT WILL MAKE
ANY DIFFERENCE ANYWAY.
>> Laura: SAME THING, I'M
GOING TO GET TO NADLER IN A
MINUTE BUT IT'S THE SAME THING
THE SUPREME COURT YESTERDAY
THROUGH CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
ISSUED A TEMPORARY STAY IN THAT
FINANCIAL RECORDS CASE WHICH WAS
ANOTHER ATTEMPT BY THE DEMOCRATS
TO THROW A WRENCH INTO THE
REELECTION BID.
WE ARE GOING TO GET ALL OF THESE
RECORDS, IT'S GOING TO LOOK BAD,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY THINK.
THEY ARE TILTING AT WINDMILLS
AND AT SOME POINT THEY SHOULD
JUST DO BETTER POLICY BUT THAT'S
TOO HARD FOR THEM.
>> THEY NEED TO REREAD
ARTICLE 1, THE LEGISLATIVE POWER
IS NOT TO GO FISHING ALL THE
TIME AND THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
>> Laura: I WANT TO MOVE TO
THIS ISSUE OF JERRY NADLER.
TODAY CHAIRMAN NADLER INVITING
PRESIDENT TRUMP NICE OF HIM AND
HIS LAWYER TO TESTIFY.
HE ALSO FIRED A WARNING SHOT
WHILE WE INVITE YOU TO THIS
HEARING, WE REMIND YOU IF YOU
CONTINUE TO REFUSE TO MAKE
WITNESSES AND DOCUMENTS
AVAILABLE TO THE COMMITTEE, THE
CHAIR WILL HAVE DISCRETION TO
IMPOSE APPROPRIATE REMEDIES.
MY STOMACH IS HURTING BECAUSE
I'M LAUGHING SO HARD ABOUT THIS
EARLIER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE IS
THREATENING BUT HOW SHOULD THE
WHITE HOUSE RESPOND?
>> THEY OUGHT TO SAY GO AHEAD,
BRING ANOTHER SUIT AND WE WILL
TAKE IT UP TO THE SUPREME COURT
AGAIN.
THERE'S A THING BASIC CALLED
SEPARATION OF POWERS.
THE EXECUTIVE DOESN'T WORK FOR
THE LEGISLATURE, THIS IS NOT A
PARLIAMENTARY SYSTEM WE HAVE.
THEY HAVE OVERSIGHT ABILITY BUT
THESE FISHING EXPEDITIONS WITH
OBVIOUS POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS TO
TRY AND DIG UP DIRT ON THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS, I THOUGHT
THAT WAS WHAT WE WEREN'T
SUPPOSED TO DO.
>> Laura: ONE POINT, WHAT IS
THE PENALTY?
HE HAS TO GET A COURT TO IMPOSE
A PENALTY CORRECT?
IT'S NOT LIKE NADLER IS GOING TO
GET SOME U.S. MARSHALS TO GO
OVER TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SLAPPED MANACLES ON THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS COUNSEL, IT'S
THE MOST RIDICULOUS THING I HAVE
EVER HEARD.
DO THEY NOT KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS?
I'M BEGINNING TO WONDER.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
REMEDIES, WHAT IS HE TALKING
ABOUT?
IN ANY EVENT, THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH HAS A MUCH BIGGER POLICE
FORCE IN THE CAPITOL POLICE
SERVING THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THAT'S A PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS
THREAT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: I'M GLAD YOU SAID
THAT.
>> THERE WAS A LINE IN THE
DISTRICT COURT OPINION THAT
TALKED ABOUT INHERENT
CONGRESSIONAL POWER TO JAIL
PEOPLE IN A JAIL CELL IN THE
CAPITAL IF THEY DON'T SHOW UP TO
TESTIFY.
PERHAPS THAT'S WHAT HE'S
THINKING ABOUT.
IT WOULD BE FUN TO SEE THEM TRY
THAT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: THE OBAMA JUDGE
THROUGH THAT ONE OUT THERE, I